I have shed friends every season of my
life my close Circle has always been
very very small very very small
very very small
very small
um
I also feel like I grow really quickly
because I don't hold on to things long
the moment something doesn't provide me
value I shed it I think about my life in
three to five year Seasons first I was a
high school womanizer for the most part
and then I was also like really deeply
angry I had high school friends that
when I left High School I basically
stopped being in contact with them and
then I had my come to Jesus where my dad
was like you suck as human you have
terrible reputation maybe you should
stop being who you are cleaned up my ACT
I stopped drinking nearly as much as I
was I started going to school and
studying 12 hours a day present the
fraternity and that was my college
season and I had College friends and
then when I left College I pretty much
stopped being in contact with anyone
that I went to college with most people
suck at most things and aren't Bound for
greatness because of who they are and
the choices they're willing to make the
stories about friends leaving the
hometown and no longer remember where
they're from is one that is told by
Society because Society is the majority
the majority of people get left behind
if you look at the things that you want
to get in life there's a price for them
you don't buy everything you see in the
mall why not because you don't want to
pay the price just because you might
think that a shirt or jacket is cool
just because you think an outcome is
awesome you might not be willing to make
the trade winners and losers have the
same goals the goal doesn't make you
unique it's the willingness to pay the
price that makes you unique because I'm
like everyone wants to be rich one of
the reasons that I cut people out sooner
than most is because I do not like the
labels they speak over me one of the big
things with identity is the labels that
we say about ourselves I am ex I am
impatient I am angry I am whatever right
I am poor I don't like saying it people
in your past have the identity that they
know you as and then they will speak and
they will beat that label into you
because you're not matching their
pattern why have you changed you are X
you are why and you're trying to not be
that because you're doing something
different than changing you're growing
but they see it as change and that's why
the best response in the world to
someone who says hey you've changed is
to say yeah you have it the amount you
like or love someone is directly
proportional what you are willing to
give up to maintain the relationship for
example if there's a piece of [ __ ] car
right you work on it all the time you
might say that guy must really love it
because of how much time he puts into
that thing this guy must really love his
country because he's willing to give his
life for it what are you willing to give
in exchange to maintain the relationship
if you're not willing to give up
basically anything to maintain their
relationship
then how much do you love them I think
it's been a very helpful filter for me
to say not do I love my friends but
which friends do I love the most which
friends am I willing to sacrifice the
most to keep the relationship and I am a
big believer in utility there is an
exchange in every relationship you get
something and they get something back
people don't like the idea that
relationships are transactional
but they are transactional just has a
commercial vibe to it but if we just
think about it as from a behavior
standpoint you've got two things that
can happen a behavior is reinforced or
it is punished that's it when you have
exchanges quite literally with people
those exchanges are either reinforced or
they're punished part of the strength of
the relationship is how long you're
willing to wait for the next time that
relationship is reinforced if you have a
long history of positive experiences
with a person you're willing to wait a
longer period of time if they're going
through a breakup they're having a hard
time to keep the relationship going but
at some point even if you've been
friends with somebody for 10 years if
there's just not any positive
reinforcement at some point
you do cut it off the people who are
surrounded with when we grow up it's
very unlikely just from a population
standpoint that they're going to be
great statistically that they're going
to be the top one percent or point one
percent is unlikely so it would make
sense that you change your friends over
time why do people get so weird about
keeping relationships that don't serve
them I think it's just because we have a
societal story around it that you're a
bad friend but I could also think of me
being as a good friend to my next friend
that I just made room for there's gonna
be a friend who's going to move in to my
spot on my buddy's calendar who does
want to do fantasy football who does
want to drink with him on Sunday so it's
not this like all right I'll go to the
game with you but I'm not drinking oh
dude you're not gonna come on man
because the other guy's like yeah shots
all around and they're gonna have a
blast they would better be served with
people who want the same things as them
just because I'm not seeing them anymore
doesn't mean that I don't wish them well
but if someone only tells you the
stories when you got [ __ ] up and while
you did that stupid thing they're
encouraging you in retelling in the
story of who you used to be and you want
people around you who don't believe the
lies you used to tell about yourself the
character trait shift is not a binary
it's how patient are you how kind are
you how loyal are you how honest are you
and so you want people who encourage you
in the behaviors that you want to be
like and this is why I like shedding
identities is such a core part of
Entrepreneurship is that you have to be
willing to say I am no longer this way I
will no longer behave in this way and I
don't accept that reality as truth many
of the people I had around me hey
weren't willing to pay the price that I
was willing to pay for the things that I
wanted but also wanted me to give them
more than I was willing to and so I'll
give you a story that will paint me in a
bad light and that's fine there was a
teacher that I grew up with in high
school and he's the one who stayed with
me after school for a year and worked
out with me two hours a day and you
taught me how to work out I got in shape
got more confidence better at school
from there that snowballed into me
getting into fitness huge Catalyst
snowball somebody heard that story and
then found the teacher and they linked
us he was like hey man I'm not asking
for a lot I would love to just have like
a two-hour quality every week
that was like two hour call every week
I was like I don't even talk to my
mother that much I don't talk to anybody
that much talk to my wife that's it the
value of the relationship was in the
past you may be like Alex you're a
horrible person and that's possible
maybe I am I was not willing to give two
hours a week 100 hours a year for the
rest of my life
to pay a debt for somebody who worked
out with me because we only have so much
Juju we only have so much time we have
so much Focus so much energy that we can
pour into things and if you're not
putting all your energy in One Direction
it's scattered and then you don't move
as fast my closest friend I spent one
hour a week with every week my closest
friend like clockwork it's my highest
party meeting it is something that
brings me joy and we get lots of
exchange with one another he's the one
who helps me write my book Dr Kashi Dr
Kashi here I get a lot from that now if
I didn't get anything from that over
time slow down the communication between
us I would make it every other week once
a month if you slow down your
communication cages with someone how
frequently you see them and when you
accept invitations it naturally Fizzles
but if it gets to a point where if
someone's like so close that it would be
obvious and a conversation needs to be
had
I encourage you to just have it you want
to be a kind person and the way you are
kind is that you tell the truth and you
just be honest and the easiest way that
I can tell you to be honest is you know
when you talk about somebody behind
their back just say it to them it's like
yeah Sandra's been like all over the
place lately and she's like I don't
drink it a little bit too much Sandra
you've been all over the place lately
you've been drinking a little bit too
much I'm just not sure if I want to
associate with that right now people
just don't have the balls to do that but
if you do that I promise you either have
better relationships or you'll be done
with this Mickey Mouse [ __ ] of not
even being in a real relationship and
not wanting to confront reality because
you may have a shot at getting them to
realize that they're not on the path
that they wanted to be on because you
were friends with him at some point and
so either your goals have changed or
theirs have if you listen to Kobe's
interviews where he talks about his
friends he says very explicitly that
he's willing to put everything on the
Altar for his dream now some people may
make the argument that's not quote
healthy the question that we're
answering here is not how do we do
healthy stuff question is how do we
become the greatest people will judge
you on how you spend time and their
judgments are simply Expressions that
they would not spend their time the same
way you do hey you work a lot and I
could say hey you don't
to the same degree it's like you spend
so much time with your kids
right if I say it like that people like
wait no I'm supposed to it's only the
supposed to this the thing that gives
all the emotional charge to these
conversations otherwise it's just
observing reality you can't expect to do
the same thing everyone else is doing
and somehow achieve a different outcome
once you have the vacuum of friends
because you'll probably have weeded
people out then the best thing to do is
join communities and then you'll make
friends with people in those communities
who have the same goals as you and then
if you crush it because you understand
that volume is the answer and time is
the ingredient you're going to rise in
that community and you'll gain more
status and you'll start hanging out with
people who are at the top of that
community and then you can LeapFrog into
other communities it's just lunch tables
on steroids I've wanted to live a rare
life and so I will have to be surrounded
by Rare people and rare people are by
definition rare they're not common My
Hope Is that the people that I meet now
are trying to go all the way with me I
want to do epic [ __ ] if I die and don't
do epic [ __ ] I will be bummed how much
am I willing to endure or sacrifice in
order to maintain that relationship that
I have with my dream if I have many many
friends over different seasons I'm
totally cool with that thank you for
that season it was awesome I I don't
believe things need to be forever to be
good and it's only the romantic story
that we were told of friends for life
Etc if you die with one good friend or
two good friends like you've had a
really good life